hey what is up guys mkbhd here and the
other day google made their keyboard for
android available in the play store the
stock google keyboard that comes on all
the nexus devices they kind of picked it
out of android and made it available in
the google play store now this was not
immediately seen as a big deal by anyone
i mean you can get tons of keyboards in
the play store for free even there's
swipe there's swiftkey there's even
third party duplicates or replicas of
the google keyboard and the play store
but
this is actually a bigger deal than it
seems at first because if you look at
the timeline if you look back at what
google's been doing over the past couple
of years with android this fits into
their plan and it's kind of an important
thing so looking back google actually
has a long and slow but very deliberate
history of bringing android core apps
that were originally built into android
and making them available for everyone
officially now when you get an official
google app in the play store you know
it's going to be updated every time
google finds a bug fix or wants to add a
feature and some apps like google talk
google search google calendar all these
sorts of things are already built into
android like chrome and music and even
sound search for google play have been
built into android and now are being
shoveled off into the play store it's
subtle but it is very important subtle
difference it's about context at this
point google has a ton of apps that
they're maintaining and updating through
google play about five or six pages in
the play store of apps that are just in
android being updated officially from
google as the official developer now
there can be replicas or duplicates of
others that google isn't updating so for
example the google clock app in jelly
bean it's not in the play store it's
built into the core of android but you
can grab a third-party replica of it
from the play store it's not google's
but it's about as close as you can get
we could as time goes on eventually see
all of android's core in the play store
so the sms app a calendar app the
gallery app the dialer app the people
app maybe even the full android launcher
someday officially supported from google
having the google version is pretty much
always better than having a replica of
the google version because when google
decides to add a new feature it'll be
added to the play store version and
everyone can get it rather than someone
trying to code and make it available for
every phone when google ads it it gets
added to everyone but what's more
important here is the fact that they're
moving it to the play store before if
there was a bug in a core system part of
android like the keyboard they would
have to roll out an over-the-air update
of the entire operating system to fix
that bug built into the os because the
keyboard was part of the os if it was
just a small bug they might wait for a
whole bunch of small bugs to accumulate
and then roll out a larger system update
and that's when you'd see your nexus
update for something like 4.1.1 to 4.1.2
but if there's just one major security
update that needs to be fixed quickly
that can be a bit of a problem because
dealing with carriers and getting a
major os update out to everyone is just
about impossible so with moving core
apps from android to the play store and
freeing them from the spine of google
and being updated individually one after
another papa pow pow that makes it way
easier for android and google as a whole
to keep track of everything and update
everyone without having to deal with
over-the-air updates of an entire
operating system so with this android is
becoming what we'd like to call a
rolling release and if you're a
developer you've heard this term before
if you're a software maker you've heard
this term there are several different
types of rolling releases there are
fully rolling releases and there are
partly rolling releases android is
pulling itself into the
partially rolling releases category it's
a partly rolling release because there
are so many different parts of android
that are being pulled out of it and
updated through the play store that
actual android os updates will be few
and far between there will be major
overhauls rather than smaller 4.1.1 to
4.1.2 update actual android updates will
be a big deal each time they happen but
alongside each of those big deal steps
forward there are hundreds of little
rolling releases of all the different
apps inside of android rolling alongside
those big incremental upgrades it's a
nice refreshing change of pace because
that's not always the case we always see
apple getting a really good job done of
getting their new operating system out
to all of their phones because they
control that really tightly android is
open source they don't control that
quite as tightly so slowly taking back
android taking back parts of android one
by one into a partly rolling release
schedule is uh it's a smart thing it's
subtle like we said but it's smart this
is also good because verizon is
especially bad verizon sucks when it
comes to updating phones let's take a
look back at the verizon galaxy nexus
there was a whole rant video that
actually did if you want to watch that
i'll put it below the like button but
the verizon galaxy nexus first of all
came out a few months after the
international galaxy nexus verizon also
had their way with bloatware pushed
bloatware upon the phone and then had
their way with over-the-air updates so
they basically held every over-the-air
update hostage until they could force
their bloatware into it again and make
it their way verizon just killed the
nexus experience with the verizon galaxy
nexus and you could probably say google
learned their lesson from that and
decided i don't think we want to deal
with that again and now they're just
bringing out parts of android and
dealing with it themselves so google is
taking android back from the carriers
and from the manufacturers mostly from
the carriers that have been holding back
your over there updates from so long and
being able to give them to you faster so
there you go good work google props to
you again way to take cues from apple
and way to learn your lesson from
verizon being a piece of crap
uh yeah so there you go thanks for
watching this video if you enjoyed it
definitely feel free to hit thumbs up
below and there's also a subscribe
button below if you want to watch more
videos like this in the future either
way this has been mkbhd thank you for
watching and i'll talk to you guys in
the next one
peace
you